[Música]
olá estou muito feliz porque no ted x e
essa aqui não é a minha cara de
conformada e vou mostrar pra vocês qual
é a cara de conformada é essa
nem parece né tô aí na pracinha em
frente à minha casa meu time da casa
tinha uns 8 anos de idade está aí com a
minha irmã
estou muito inconformada é difícil de
ver porque a aposta é um pouco antigas a
embaçar dinha eu vou mostrar pra vocês o
motivo do inconformismo estava nos meus
pés
eu não podia andar descalça aos oito
anos eu desenvolvi um tipo de alergia
que me impedia de andar descalça eu
tenho alergia a sapatos com material
sintético acham quente a tudo e os pés e
carvão criar bolhas a ponta dos dedos a
peão então todo dia eu sofri um pouco
aquele diagnóstico na verdade me adoeceu
só porque é que todo dia fazia parte de
uma turma a gente ia para a pracinha que
as crianças faziam quando chegava na
pracinha primeira coisa tiravam chinelos
e coloca a mão debaixo de uma árvore
no entanto acaba no braço como se fosse
um escudo podia tirar meus pés meias
andada tinham duas coisas a gente que eu
queria com a alma
primeiro era andar descalça na pracinha
a segunda coisa era de que chute pro
colégio colégio de padre se no religioso
radical não é família uma família
católica praticante o dia chegando da
escola
olha só o que eu vejo objeto diferente
na estante um livro grande capa dura
lindo letras douradas
a bíblia sagrada e uma bíblia sagrada
ilustrada
então peguei aquele livro com muita
vontade de ver as gravuras me encantei
até chegar com algumas imagens como essa
várias imagens de jesus ali
representando é alguma passagem é
colocada em algumas páginas de uma
sequência de imagens peguei aquele livro
com o coração na boca e fui lá falar com
a minha mãe se eu devo segundo jesus eu
tenho que andar descalça é claro ela
segurou a onda tem o meu sorriso e aí
ela disse assim pra mim bem séria gênero
e as duas era muito pobre
eu fiquei mais indignada porque o pai
dele fazia móvel é um carpinteiro porque
é que não fazia um chinelo para o filho
dele que é pra mim até hoje fazem um
chinelo coisa muito simples eu nunca fiz
chinelo nenhum mas eu penso que fazemos
é algo muito simples eu segui
questionadora inconformada crescendo é
antes disso né
antes de continuar com esse conformes
nesse momento da da bíblia e logo depois
com esses meus questionamentos eu pude
perceber uma coisa importante que ficou
pra vida
o inconformado que não tem argumento ele
é um chato um chato
o inconformado tem um bom propósito e um
bom argumento ele pode conseguir uma
mudança e eu me agarrei essas três
palavras positivas virou um combo na
minha vida em conformismo mais propósito
mais argumento é igual a mudança e os
seguir que é chamado hora na sala de
aula os professores reclamavam mandar um
bilhete para os meus pais já une
pergunta muito atrapalha a aula vices
bilhetinhos só porque olha só eu é até
complicado a gente questionadora
pra sermos muito passivos e porque para
não incomodar para não afrontar para não
dar trabalho é feito com o lateral
preguiça a gente começa até vontade de
não ter trabalho também é normal agora
uma fase é eu já tenho 30 11 eu estou
diante de um sonho meu filho iso meu
sonho
gente eu sonhei ser mãe eu queria só ser
mãe eu não queria ser o pâncreas e aos
nove meses meu filho foi diagnosticado
com diabetes méxico 1 e sulino
dependente
eu não gostei disso
eu não estava preparada logo depois meu
pai adoeceu
adivinha que ele tinha câncer no
pâncreas
eu fiquei muito revoltada e eu fiz um
texto vai para outras que pariu eu tinha
que desabafar porque a gente ouve falar
e todos os órgãos
a gente ouve falar em coração e pulmão e
fígado
ninguém escuta falar no pâncreas
alguém fala pra você toca o dono pontos
ninguém diz ele fala então não sabia
exatamente meio que o pâncreas fazia e
diante daquele sofrimento inicial que
todos os as palavras negativas com i no
começo eu estava indignada eu me sentia
injustiçada e inconformada com aquele
diagnóstico e aí gente
é eu tive que me h á a informação porque
é toda informação ela liberta e ela me
libertou de bate pronto eu entendi uma
coisa é eu não podia subestimar a
condição do eso como portador de
diabetes e nem deveria ficar hafei
daquela condição uma coisa
logo depois veio para me mostrar que
aquele inconformismo
era válido mas eu tava ganhando alguns
presentes tipo eu passei a ser prescrita
pelos médicos nos hospitais e
consultórios como a mãe que poderia
acalmar outras mães
o telefone era passado e às vezes eu
tinha que na casa da família o hospital
da injeção de ânimo dos pais e aplicar a
primeira insulina no filho deles para
mostrar que não era tão ruim assim
foi importante isso pra mim
um ano depois um ano depois essa
história isso o diagnóstico eu mais
tranquila mas aliviar
enfim tem vida conheci pan crianças e
como você compre eu resolvi fazer uma
missa em ação de graça para agradecer a
deus né fim um ano isso bem eu estava
bem e eu achei que devia ter via para as
pessoas algo mais informação aquilo que
eu tinha aprendido gente até hoje assim
a pergunta que mais fazem pra jeanne por
onde ela anda como foi diagnosticado
diabetes do seu filho eu acho que eu já
respondi isso um milhão de vezes e aí eu
resolvi então leva pra missa aflito uefs
mil panfletos comecei a panfletar na
missa e zucon aneel já havia alguma
coisa é o texto bem lúdico bem leve e já
apresentando a sua condição de diabético
tipo 1 como era a vida dele como havia
sido é como foi feito o diagnóstico e
dando informações relevantes para as
pessoas leigas porque é de como elas
deveriam se portar diante de uma família
de um portador de diabetes
isso pra mim foi muito importante ter
colocado porque eu queria integrar o iso
numa rotina normal de uma criança mas
era complicado chegar num shopping em
tirar um estudo da bolsa e aplicar o que
a pessoa que estava do lado vir me
consolar chamando ele de coitado eu
estava lutando para fortalecer alta
cima dele vocês entendem eu precisava
dizer para as pessoas que elas não
olharem o diabético como se ele fosse um
coitado e o mais interessante foi ver o
seguinte uma corrente que se formou a
partir desse panfleto não tinha rede
social esse tempo que aconteceu eu fiz
mil panfletos as pessoas foram vendo
pedindo pra si pra a doar mais mil mais
mais mil por fim a gráfica foi a última
doador pegue a filha mais mil panfletos
possa assim um tempão distribuindo isso
e foi muito interessante é ver essa
corrente e como eu faço conexão o todas
as coisas que acontecem a vida eu pude
perceber nesse momento a lei do retorno
ela é certa a gente dá a gente recebe
meu próximo momento foi de mãe pátria
cidadã porque a gente exagera o cidadão
criança doente crónico e aí o governo
que temos paraíso
nesse tempo eu pensava muito doença
trabalhando para o meu umbigo vocês
estão falando só dele é depois foi tal
que a luta se transformou então eu
descobrir logo é o artigo 196 da
constituição federal tão antiga tem uma
frase linda a saúde é direito de todos e
dever do estado isso acontece gente
porque nós temos planos de saúde porque
o estado não está fazendo o dever de
casa direitinho
depois de descobrir a lei 11.340 e 7
posicionada logo anos é quando depois
que ele foi diagnosticado com diabetes é
a lei mais importante da comunidade
diabética brasileira porque ela
regulamenta o fornecimento de
medicamentos e de insumos
só que essa lei não é aplicada em sua
integralidade
já que é essa lei prevê que o rol de
medicamentos dispensados deve acompanhar
a evolução do tratamento
e isso nunca aconteceu por isso
hoje no brasil é judicializada eu mesmo
precisei precisei correr ao mini ao
ministério público
mesmo tendo uma lei federal que dizia
que meu filho tinha que receber o
medicamento dele
olha só gente é muito triste saber que
eu fiz as pessoas não conheciam a lei
europeia o meu carro com a lei andava
com essa lei está ampara vá atrás do seu
medicamento porque as pessoas precisam
ser empoderadas e ela só podem fazer
isso será checar e conhecimento dos
direitos dela então foi aí nesse momento
que eu andei com uma louca meu carro só
eu no mundo com um número de uma lei e
pedindo para as pessoas tentarem
descobrir o que é isso
bem gente é esse
nesse caminho nesse caminho todo assim
eu pude me indignava quando comecei a
ver muitas realidades a realidade do
brasil e me questionar é esse país que
na verdade a gestões tratam muito mais a
doença do que da saúde focam muito mais
na doença em si do que na educação do
que na próxima disse na educação e saúde
eu concluo que se morre é de pobre no
brasil não é de diabetes
a grande maioria das pessoas que estão
no limbo agora nesse momento elas estão
unindo de pobre que a pobreza começa
pelo desconhecimento da própria condição
que é complexa das leis que são que não
quisessem que elas desconhecem
então gente é eu estou me deparando com
muitas histórias e foi aí que eu comprei
a dor do outro tem uma história para
contar pra vocês muito triste ela é e
nunca esqueço essa história porque me
comovi muito até hoje eu descobri uma
dessas minhas caminhadas uma moça
chamada francis ilha ela foi
diagnosticada com diabetes quando ela
tinha 10 anos de idade dia que eu fui
conversar com francine a próxima etapa
fazendo diálise no hospital getúlio
vargas e trouxe lhe tava todas as
complicações já é
instaladas ali naquele corpo frágil
francesa tinha insuficiência renal
insuficiência cardíaca grave e
financeira estava cega e francílio tinha
o mesmo tempo de diabetes do meu filho
eu nunca me conformei com essa história
eu tenho uma coisa pra dizer pra vocês
que me tocou também bastante france um
dia revelou que enquanto ela estava
perdendo a visão enquanto lia o livro o
caçador de pipas francia morreu aos 22
anos
eu não queria mais ver francílio
sofrendo e morrendo daquela forma mas eu
não tenho só histórias ruins pra contar
não viu gente eu quero contar agora uma
história muito boa
2011 foi um ano do diabético aqui na
nossa capital
levei um vereador a idéia de um projeto
de lei que atendesse todos os diabéticos
teresinenses
além do medicamento para que todos
tivessem acesso já que a lei federal não
funcionava
o vereador cobrou a idéia da lei e
apresentou e todos os vereadores foram
favoráveis
eu fiquei sabendo pelo twitter e começou
o movimento assina é humano durante
cinco ou seis horas de um tuitaço
abraçado por centenas de teresinenses
nós colocamos a nossa tag em primeiro
lugar foi o assunto mais comentado
durante uma tarde inteira o assunto mais
comentado no twitter no brasil e isso
fez com que é o brasil tivesse
conhecimento vamos parar nos portais de
referência diabetes e saúde e aí o
movimento começou que não sabia é o
prefeito recebeu documento da aprovação
dos vereadores ele e deu tempo pra poder
decidir pelo velho
tu não dividir aquela que lhe tempo de
um mês a minha cabeça o tempo é de
sensibilização o outro é de mobilização
mas eu não vou falar primeiro com o
prefeito esse movimento tem que ser
voltado a princípio para a sociedade
se a sociedade comprasse abraçasse o
assim é humano
o elmano já teria motivo para sancionar
e assim nós produzimos esse trabalho e
aí gente veio a fase da mobilização e
uma semana organizamos uma caminhada
linda cultura que vocês podem imaginar
diga o carro de som boneco gigante
portadores de diabetes as pessoas que eu
não conhecia as pessoas mais importantes
da minha vida hoje porque com elas eu
pude me fortalecer porque até então não
conhecia a comunidade diabética e este
foi impressionante porque eu senti
também que além da sociedade a imprensa
abraçava assinaelmano o bacana foi no
outro dia pelos jornais frases como essa
à imprensa imparcial tinha um lado o dos
diabéticos
eu me arrepio até hoje quando eu ganhei
essa frase
foram muitas as manifestações em blogs
foi muito interessante ver eu nunca
tinha visto daquela forma vê a imprensa
impasse ao se posicionar e tem um lado e
sabe o que aconteceu gente
o prefeito vetou a lei porque eu fiz
isso me refiz junto àquele grupo que foi
lá para a caminhada que eu conheci
criamos a associação dos diabéticos do
piauí
o veto veio o inconformismo feio quatro
meses depois estávamos com a associação
constituída com a
está tudo cnpj nesse momento nós já
podíamos falar pela comunidade
diabéticas de fato e de direito
vocês não se imagina o que é o que é
poder representar essas pessoas tão
carentes de uma voz
essa imagem é da última reunião com os
portadores de diabetes
se nós fizéssemos só as reuniões para os
aqui em teresina a deep já valeria mais
adiante não faz só isso eu quero dizer
que não sábado à tarde duas e meia da
tarde
nesse clima de teresina esse público
carente vai no sol do baby o próprio a
esse lugar e passa uma tarde incrível
porque a gente trabalha com a autoestima
com troca de experiência positiva e as
injeções de ânimos
as pessoas entram de um jeito e sai de
outros já dizendo eu conto as horas e os
dias para estar aqui é isso
as reuniões eram de começaram a sala da
minha casa e hoje a gente já passamos
por vários auditórios para poder
acomodar as pessoas e hoje nós estamos
num espaço que vão faz 100 e 150 pessoas
nesse clima e solo sábado à tarde
emociona muito emoção também é ver que
quatro anos a gente trabalha sem
dinheiro mas também sem dificuldade por
que uma ong é feita de parceria um é de
dinheiro não
a gente tem uma coisa que a gente
continue chamada reputação é isso que
alimenta a dip
nunca deixamos de fazer nada porque não
tínhamos dinheiro porque as parcerias
vinham as pessoas vinham até nós e
ofereciam e sabe que é mais bacana de
não ter dinheiro é ver a felicidade das
pessoas sabem do que estão sul mando pra
ver algo muito bom aparecer e dá
resultado
oportunidade das pessoas se sentirem
úteis é também o papel da adi por isso
nós é que somos gratos aos nossos
parceiros
afinal qual o segredo
duas semanas depois o tuitaço eu recebi
uma ligação com essa pergunta era um
educador um professor já estou aqui da
nossa cidade querendo fazer um movimento
nas redes sociais
e aí queria saber coluna tinha
conseguido colocar uma tag em primeiro
lugar no brasil e em uma rede social
eu não soube responder gente
honestamente eu não soube responder
só porque eu sou eu não soube responder
naquele dia agora eu sei responder
eles querem a resposta sabe o que é que
levou a tag lá pra cima sabe o que é que
miley fez com que a deep surgisse
sabe o que me trouxe até aqui
o tal do inconformismo conformismo
produtivo é isso que eu estou falando
para vocês de inconformismo produtivo
feito com verdade porque na verdade meus
amigos é a verdade que alimenta uma
pessoa as relações uma vida uma onde uma
empresa jornalismo a publicidade e que
alimenta a deep e as pessoas sempre é
souberam entender que tinha os
propósitos eram bons que aquela causa
tinha valor e que tinha muita verdade
ali por trás também quatro anos depois
da fundação da associação dos diabéticos
do piauí nossa nosso estado que a gente
pode ver nós inspiramos contagiamos
promovemos mudanças
eu quero dizer uma coisa abril para
dizer aqui a dizer que não é jeanne o
frágil que fez isso tudo foi um grupo de
pessoas várias pessoas não conseguiria
nada sozinha gente ninguém consegue
nada só e até agora eu lembro de alguma
palestra até de que eu assistir e que a
palestrante disse o seguinte se você
quiser chegar bem rápido algum lugar lá
sozinha mas se você quiser chegar bem
longe
wako o estado quais suas pessoas
os seus amigos com desconhecidos que
abraçarem aquilo que você abraça eu
apostei muito nisso e eu tenho amigos
anjos amigos pessoas muito queridas que
abraçaram o meu inconformismo e eu sou
eternamente grata por essas pessoas
inspiramos contagiamos e hoje gente nós
somos espelhos para outras 20
instituições
hoje nós enviamos ata estatuto o que a
gente faz para virar espelho para que
outras entidades suja é muito
interessante ver uma felicidade ver por
exemplo que a associação dos diabéticos
de caxias nasceu com o suporte da deep
que outra agora nasce lá no pará
o que está em contato com a gente a
gente está alimentando de informação
para que eles possam trabalhar
direitinho para que eles possam também
conduzir seus diabéticos a melhor forma
no taco políticas públicas eficientes
isso é uma coisa que eu me orgulho hoje
falar pra vocês me dirigi me revolta na
resultado é que hoje nós fazemos contas
diferente as contas são outras quantas
pessoas deixaram de ser amputadas por
conta do nosso trabalho
eu estou fazendo mais aquela conta
porque o piauí realmente nos envergonha
50% dos amputados em nosso estado são
importadores de abbass pessoas que não
foram educadas que não foram é que eu
tiveram acesso a um tratamento adequado
ao ao medicamento adequado é um dado
impressionante porque seu curta mais
diabéticos do que pessoas que sofre de
acidentes automobilísticos hoje nosso
estado é um dado e padre tati
e nós junto com aquele gestor que fez o
veto lá aquela nossa lei depois nos
tornamos parceiros e nós criamos junto
com essa gestão
o primeiro ambulatório de feridas e pé
diabético e hoje é o centro de
assistência ao diabético cade que
funciona ali no lineu araújo projeto
feito por nós também construímos essas
coisas lembra que eu falei da lecce não
mando municipal não foi sancionada a lei
6.623 foi sancionada e 30 de dezembro de
a gente estava querendo uma lei
municipal quando foi vetada a gente
criou a deep resolvem só não queria mais
lei municipal que querem queremos uma
lei estadual e ela for sancionado quatro
anos depois coloca do inconformismo
a receita está fresquinha e agora a
gente continua trabalhando porque ela
foi sancionada mas ela precisa sair do
papel e o governo precisa criar uma
logística criar criar condições para que
ela não seja uma lei na ti mostra pra
que ela é vida às pessoas nessas
histórias de mês e muitos já foram
sancionados por meio da adi por essa eu
tenho um carinho muito especial ela tem
um carimbo no carinho vai lá tem um nome
do meu filho é a lei enzo
a lei foi uma surpresa
na verdade os vereadores logo após o
veto é a lei municipal se reuniram e
viram que os diabéticos tinha um símbolo
na nossa capital que era o meu filho e
hoje o dia municipal de combate ao
diabetes é o dia do aniversário do meu
mesmo
eu vivo muito feliz por isso porque esua
sendo criado está crescendo nesse
ambiente solidário altruísta
nesse ambiente que me conecta a deus
quando o trabalho pradip na verdade eu
estou rezando
eu posso fazer um pedido pra vocês agora
para encerrar sejam inconformados
obrigada de coração
[Aplausos]